bill belichick apparently does not miss
tom brady he held a conference call
prior to the draft on tuesday and
brady's name came up obviously because
it was the first time belichick spoke to
reporters since tom brady chose to leave
the patriots and sign with the tampa bay
buccaneers and one of the questions that
still lingers is did the patriots or did
the patriots want tom brady back anyway
and uh that was a question that was
posed to belichick did you want brady
back in 2020 and here's what he had to
say
yeah i think that's uh you know a lot of
water under the bridge mike and like i
said we're really focused on
this season and
trying to
look at our opportunities and make
decisions and
plan and prepare to
be as competitive as we can be this year
so
that's really what our focus is on
first of all that sounded impressive
because he said my name but i wasn't the
mic he was answering it presumably mike
reese of espn.com i had a little moment
there where i thought you know i'm just
going to let that go and let people
think that he was talking specifically
to me but we we need to be transparent
we need to be honest we need to be
candid it wasn't me chris
no it wasn't you but i thought the same
thing nonetheless but you know what did
you expect any other answer from a guy
like bill belichick i mean this is one
of the most focused uh individuals we've
ever seen in professional sports i mean
this is a guy that's famous for
being on the plane ride back for the
super bowl
and not even discussing the game already
on to next year and talking about moves
he's gonna have to make within the you
know the coaching staff and players and
whatever it may be and scheduling the
off season so you know again
belichick i do think wanted brady back i
do i just don't think he was gonna you
know break the bank to get brady back i
think there was a line that that could
not be crossed and i think that was the
big thing and that's usually the case
with belichick he's business as always
with just about everybody go ahead yeah
what do you think the line was what do
you think he was willing to pay him
i'm gonna say it was somewhere like 20
maybe 23 maybe i'm going to say around
that 18 to 20 mark though i don't think
he wanted to go anywhere near 25 or get
into the 30 range
i know our buddy tom curran of nbc
sports boston is a believer that
the patriots were standing on whatever
offer they made to brady last august
that he basically laughed at and they
were waiting for brady to counter that
that they weren't going to make a new
offer and brady never counted it so
that's kind of how belichick finds
some sort of a safe harbor in this whole
breakdown of communication from their
perspective an offer was on the table
and brady never responded to it so they
never had a chance to engage him and get
to that that number whatever that number
was if it was close or not close we
never knew because they never actually
had a negotiation chris
well i you know and that i think this
tells you a little bit more that one
probably brady was a a little bit
disrespected by the contract offer you
know but also i think that just shows
another inkling that like he had had it
he just had it he was worn out worn out
by the organization the tactics of
belichick you know the fact that he
feels like he's probably underpaid and
underappreciated for a number of amount
of years and i think that's why you
heard him say last week in the howard
stern interview that he probably knew
before the 2019 season that he wanted to
move on or that it was done nonetheless
because of that offer i'm sure that told
him a lot
and belichick has mastered the art of
saying nothing obviously that's not news
to anyone who has paid attention to him
but before brady leaves if he's asked
about brady and whether or not brady's
going to be with the team next year all
he has to say
is well that none of that matters i'm
not thinking about the future i'm
thinking about right now i'm thinking
about making the team better then once
he's gone while that's water under the
bridge you never have to talk about it
right it reminds me of bill polian when
he was with the colts and a season ended
poorly and he was asked questions about
the season and how it ended and he had
some stupid line like the past is
prologue there's no point talking about
it well well
yes there is
and it is amazing to me how so many of
these guys in football just through
sheer force of their personality will
with a straight face pull off
not having to talk about anything chris
that they just don't want to talk about
no well i mean they're just afraid to
let anybody look under the hood and know
how they're running their organization
you know and then with this case with
bill belichick yeah he's he's extremely
detailed he does things differently than
the rest of football he doesn't want
anybody to know what he's thinking or
what his plan of attack was
uh and that's just the way he runs
business you know but you know i think
at the end of the day with belichick and
brady i mean you know the one thing that
just jumps out to me is how many times
during the season last year we got
little inklings that brady might not be
you know it doesn't sound like brady
will be back i didn't believe it i
thought when it all came down to it that
brady would be back in new england and
he would just go man do i really want to
make this switch or not but obviously
you know we're starting to connect dots
and see more and more things here to
where
yeah it's not a fractured relationship
but it just came to the end and i think
you know brady was just exhausted of
belichick and that way of life
how much do you think
that that undercurrent
impacted the performance of the team
last year if at all
i i don't i mean you know i don't think
it did you know
you know mike what do you think i mean
when i just look at it i go these are
two guys that really can stay on task
have laser focus
uh they do now you know again is
belichick a master in military tactics
and mental welfare yes definitely but i
think more times than not it gets the
best out of players and and people
within the organization and i don't
think brady is the kind of guy that
would let that affect his play he holds
himself to a standard that's the thing i
love about tom brady i mean he expects
greatness from himself you know on a
weekly basis yearly basis whatever that
may be he's putting the pressure on
himself again for 2020.
i just think no they were you know a
little inadequate on the offensive side
of the ball last year didn't have the
right weapons and of course brady for
the first time i think showed his age a
little bit towards the end of the season
and i asked that because we saw a little
flash of humanity last week from tom
brady during that two-hour interview
with howard stern and
the the normal human being and there
isn't much about tom brady that would
fall into the normal human being
category but the normal human being
when that person feels the train pulling
into the station
at a given job in a given place dealing
with a given boss
it is more difficult chris it's easy to
give into the hell i'm not going to be
here much longer anyway who cares and
you just have to wonder how much harder
brady did have to focus in his
preparation in everything that he did to
finish the right way and when we look at
the results of the season there's
evidence to point to to say you know it
didn't finish the right way because it
didn't finish the way that it had the
past several years for the patriots they
didn't get out of the wild card round
for crying out loud they'd been to the
afc championship game every season since
2011. there was something very different
about last year and it's hard to not at
least wonder
whether brady's mindset that i'm out of
here after this season did it at at some
moment at some point you know did he did
he study film as much as he should have
before a critical late regular season
game that would have determined whether
or not they had a buy you know the
dolphins game for example i mean it it's
impossible to put the trail of
breadcrumbs together right but but the
big picture is the patriots were far
below their standard last year even
though they started 8-0
no i mean mike i mean you make a lot of
good points i think those points would
hold up to like most humans like you're
saying but this isn't most humans you
know do i think brady at some point
during the season late in the year was
probably like man they don't appreciate
me damn i got a lot of young weapons
around me that are inexperienced this is
tough sledding i mean this is crazy what
they've done to me this year yes i am
sure that he had some thoughts like that
but i still think this is a new england
team
that even after they lost to miami week
17 they thought they were super bowl
caliber and hey listen you know this had
to come to an end at some point i mean
it's one of the greatest runs we've seen
in the history of professional sports
what they just went through the super
bowl runs the afc championships and
still even last year you know just
listen to us you know we're talking
about a team and going man it didn't
work out well and they didn't play well
and they were eight no at one point and
of course sitting there ready for home
field advantage or at least the number
two seed and blew that so uh you know i
just think the time had come for the
team and they're a little bit of a
rebuild mode as we're seeing right now
they're they're changing over to their
next phase of life there in new england
and i'm not gonna suggest that bill
belichick was operating five levels
higher than he ordinarily does but i
will say this he's smart enough to sense
that tom brady was on his way out weeks
before tom brady was out and as a
practical matter it makes it easier for
the patriots to move on without brady if
brady isn't walking away after taking
the team to the super bowl yet again not
definitely they want not that belichick
didn't want to get to the super bowl
again but it makes it easier for the
patriots to remove the band-aid because
the the fans saw what happened last year
and if you get to a super bowl and win
it again it would have been a hell of a
lot harder to turn the page on tom brady
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports